julia cultiva dos variedades de peras
bosque and you ella tomó una muestra de
cada variedad para probar si su
contenido calórico promedio era
significativamente diferente aquí hay un
resumen de sus resultados nos
proporcionan datos similares para ambas
muestras y una vez más tienen el mismo
tamaño de la muestra aunque esto no es
necesario pero aquí en lugar de darnos
un valor p nos dan un intervalo de
confianza
julia quiere usar estos resultados para
probar su hipótesis nula de que el
contenido calórico medio es el mismo en
comparación con su hipótesis alternativa
de que son diferentes
supongamos que se han cumplido todas las
condiciones para la inferencia con base
en el intervalo que sabemos sobre el
valor p correspondiente y la conclusión
para el nivel de significancia de alfa
igual a 0.01 entonces pausa en este
vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
recuerden lo que es un intervalo de
confianza del 99% significa que si
construimos intervalos de confianza 100
veces 99 de esas veces contendrán el
valor real del parámetro que estamos
tratando de estimar en ese caso el valor
real del parámetro es la
de estas medias ahora cuando hacemos una
prueba de hipótesis siempre comenzamos
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y si suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera bueno otra
forma de escribir esta hipótesis nula es
que si las dos medias son iguales es lo
mismo que la diferencia de las medias
igual a cero y dado que estamos
suponiendo esto y este es un intervalo
de confianza del 99% entonces 99 de cada
100 veces que hacemos esto deberíamos
ver que este intervalo contiene lo que
suponemos que es el verdadero parámetro
aquí ahora este intervalo si contiene al
0 si tomamos 4
6.44 obtendremos 2.44 negativo entonces
0 está definitivamente en el intervalo
otra forma de pensar en esto es que no
estamos en el 1% de las veces en que el
parámetro no está incluido en el
intervalo si estuviéramos en ese 1% de
las veces en que no se incluye la
diferencia supuesta entonces
rechazaríamos la hipótesis nula y otra
forma de pensar en esto es que nuestro
nivel de significancia 0.01 justo aquí
es 1
- nuestro nivel de confianza justo aquí
si nuestro intervalo de confianza del 99
por ciento contiene amor de las peras
bosco menos el contenido calórico medio
de la esperanza new igual a cero
entonces eso significa que el valor p es
mayor que 0.01 y también podríamos decir
que nuestro valor p es mayor que nuestro
nivel de significancia porque ese es
nuestro nivel de significancia y por eso
no podemos rechazar nuestra hipótesis
nula si esto no contuviera nuestra
supuesta diferencia en las medias si no
contuviera a 0 entonces estaríamos en
ese escenario de 1 entre 100 y eso nos
diría que nuestro valor p es menor que
0.01 que nuestro valor p es inferior a 1
menos nuestro nivel de confianza y en
este caso rechazaríamos la hipótesis
nula y esto sugeriría que hay una
diferencia en el contenido calórico pero
debido a que no lo rechazamos no podemos
concluir que haya una diferencia en el
contenido calórico